[Music]
cody is with us in indiana hi cody
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave um
yeah
kind of nervous not gonna lie
no trouble we've never lost a patient
you're gonna make it
um
so i'm a general contractor uh debt free
uh me and my wife got about a hundred
and four thousand dollars of capital
and
i hate people
so i'm going to work for myself rather
than a client
and uh
so my long-term goal has been won't get
into flipping houses that way i can just
let them sell them be done i got to mess
with anybody
but i've not gotten into it yet and with
everything going on the way it is i'm
kind of uh
worried about starting at the moment
okay
i gotta ask dave how are you gonna be a
general contractor my father-in-law is
very successful at it and not deal with
some people i get your general
i mean you don't want to deal with
clients nitpicking your work
no i well
that always happens regardless
you can work for 100 different people 90
of them's great 10 of them are
not so great right that's about average
yeah it's just uh
being the owner i'm constantly running
through the run to the stores
all the time
and i just want to be able to work
you're going to do all the work yourself
are you going to sub it out
uh
i'd say about what i could i mean i
don't want to cut in my costs of course
but i don't do everything i don't do
hvac i'm not licensed for that of course
okay so what about i'm with ken i don't
mind answering your question but i'm
just curious because there's times i
agree with you i love people but they
also about two percent of them should be
institutionalized so
um
you know they just they're nutty and
they're on twitter and so um what what
what is it what people are you cutting
out by doing this process
well uh client i don't have to go uh do
bids for people and then do their work i
can just
100 percent work for myself okay
and until you sell the house and they're
of course going to want you to do
uh to finish up or to to
fix whatever is broken after they move
in right you know that
unfortunately yeah that's gonna go so
you're not cutting them out completely
but you're getting rid of a lot of the
back and forth while you're doing the
job that's what you're after okay i'm
with you on that right now let's go back
to your question flipping houses well
we're in a white hot real estate market
everybody knows that right so very tough
to buy deals and part of flipping a
house or making money is you have to buy
it at a deal agreed
oh yeah absolutely and so what you've
got to be very very careful of is a no
debt
b
be so patient
that you pass on 50 deals
to get one
that works
okay i i used to buy before i went broke
i made a really good living
and and
buying and selling foreclosures i was
doing flips before chip and joanna were
born okay
and so um
but i looked at in those days i looked
at 200 deals to buy one that was my
average
because i was gonna because all the
money in real estate on flips is made at
the buy
if you buy a property and the weird
crazy white hot market where people are
paying too much is the only way you get
out of it and make money you didn't buy
the property right
yes you need to buy it at
70
72 73 of appraisal
today minus repairs
yes and then you can actually make a
profit because you're going to lose 12
percent on the resale in commissions
closing costs and negotiation off of
appraisal
unless you catch the edge of a white hot
market which we're in right now okay but
if you depend on a white hot market to
bail out your bad deal you're going to
get your butt burned
yeah that's what i don't want to happen
yeah
cheap or don't buy
and buy with debt and have a formula
minus repairs so uh you know you gotta
let's use a round number you got a
hundred thousand dollar house you're
gonna buy it for seventy two seventy
three thousand dollars it makes ten
thousand dollars worth of repairs means
you're gonna buy it for 62 000 how are
you going to find that in this world
today you might find it because it might
be so messed up nobody else wants it
because it's so freaking ugly
that even the white hot market won't
sell this white elephant okay
but they're very hot deals are hard to
find right now
and foreclosures are not happening at
the level that they were happening
because there's been a whole bunch of
people still sitting on the foreclosures
due to the moratoriums they're just
starting to re-enter the market
so a little harder to find the
foreclosure deals too
uh right now maybe by the end of summer
they will have opened back up so if
you're patient
and you just say
you know don't get all hot and bothered
about buying something and you buy it at
a deal minus repairs and you get paid to
do the repairs and then you get paid on
the transaction as a profit both things
then and you do it with no debt then
you're going to be okay
so but that's going to involve a lot of
work of finding a deal and it's very
difficult to do right now
and there's people out there flipping
houses right now and they're depending
on white hop market to bail them out and
that market's going to turn off on them
and they're going to get caught holding
that so cody dave just gave you the
formula so now you have to ask the
question how much money must i have so
what needs to be true do i need 200 000
in cash 250 to be able to get that kind
of a deal with that ratio and then make
money on it because remember you're
making really good money in your
business right now i suspect yeah and so
if you're going to switch over to
full-time flipper then you got to play
that equation out how many houses would
i have to flip to pay myself what i make
you've given him a wonderful formula now
he's going to have to be patient that's
what's going on 104 000 to invest in
flipping that um
three times a year maybe um you're
probably building some houses still yeah
that's while you're right take some time
while you're running these flips you
could run both at the same time but
having until you build your capital up
and you could get two or three flips
going at a time that's correct with
actual dollars then when you get there
you could probably step aside from doing
the contracting but you're probably
still gonna do a little contracting and
that'll also calm you down and you don't
get desperate oh i got to get a house
because i got to get income
and then that's going to cause you to
pay too much
the name of the game in this is patience
yes you know
i had a guy a mortgage company used to
buy property from after they took it
back one of these little finance
companies and he goes ramsey you're a
vulture
you're the nicest vulture i know
but you're a vulture i said well you're
right i'm kind of circling waiting on
something to die you know that's what
i'm doing you know i'm because i'm
looking for a deal i'm not mad at
anybody i'm not causing anybody any harm
i'm just going to help out when they're
there and i write a check and buy the
property but that was a long time ago
that's kind of a nice compliment in a
way it was in there it's in there
somewhere dave ramsey looking for that
real estate roadkill
that's the name of the new book real
estate real estate roadkill there it is
i was looking for a title ken david
this is what i do but you know it's
funny you know you you gave you gave
cody some great advice i love that
formula and then you said it's all about
patience in cody's world he needs some
patience with all those people he hates
just for a no
i get what he's saying though he's he's
working with clients that are just
nitpicking and driving bananas we uh
yeah i i was in the custom home building
business as a sales guy for a while and
he's right you know about nine out of 10
of them are just the greatest people in
the world but let me tell you who drives
you absolutely nuts ones are too broke
to bite ah right so now they're trying
and and so they're trying to flex up
you know and they go through the house
and they nitpick stuff that doesn't even
like scraping's gonna fix their problems
like you know like you know you're still
gonna be broke after you flex over this
drywall piece of drywall right here you
know classic yeah one guy went through
with a magic marker and he had the plan
wrong in his hand he had it backward and
he drew on the wall where the plugs were
supposed to be instead of where they
were oh boy yeah we charged him like ten
thousand dollars to go through we had to
sand and seal
and then repaint every one of those
walls and cover that stupid magic marker
that this
person so i get it i get it i get it i
understand i mean that guy the magic
marker guy that'll drive you out of the
business right there i would and so um
yeah you've got to manage those people
and manage their expectations in the
process and it's
um it's a challenge in that world it
really is